OF THEIR FINGER-POINTING
RESPONDS EXCLUSIVELY TONIGHT.
FIRST, BIDEN’S RACE TO THE
BOTTOM.
THAT’S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT’S
ANGLE.
A LONG, LONG TIME AGO, JOE BIDEN
WAS AGAINST USING EXECUTIVE
ORDERS TO RAM THROUGH WHAT IS
PROPERLY LEFT TO THE LEGISLATURE
LEGISLATURE.
>> SOME OF MY REPUBLICAN FRIENDS
AND SOME OF MY DEMOCRATIC
FRIENDS OCCASIONALLY SAY WELL,
IF YOU CAN’T GET THE VOTES BY
EXECUTIVE ORDER COMING OR GOING
TO DO SOMETHING.
THINGS YOU CAN’T DO BY EXECUTIVE
ORDER UNLESS YOU’RE A DICTATOR.
WE ARE DEMOCRACY.
WE NEED CONSENSUS.
>> Laura: THE DICTATOR THROUGH
THAT IDEA OF THE WAY NOBODY
BECAUSE THE BIDEN BRIGADE HAS A
COUNTRY TO REMAKE AND REDEEM
REDEEM.
TODAY HE CONTINUED TAKING A
WRECKING BALL TO HIS UNITY GOAL.
THE MAN WHO SERVED UP AS, HE WAS
THE VP TO THE TWO-TERM
AFRICAN-AMERICAN PRESIDENT.
HE TRIPLED DOWN ON THE NEGATIVE
VIEW THAT AMERICA AT HER CORE IS
RACIST.
>> OUR SOUL WILL BE TROUBLED AS
LONG A SYSTEMIC RACISM IS
ALLOWED TO PERSIST.
WE CAN’T ELIMINATE IT, IT’S
KNOCKING TO BE OVERNIGHT.
WE CAN’T ELIMINATE EVERYTHING.
BUT IT’S CORROSIVE.
IT’S DESTRUCTIVE AND IT’S
COSTLY.
>> Laura: TO ADDRESS THE
AFOREMENTIONED SYSTEMIC RACISM,
BIDEN SIGNED A SLEW OF EXECUTIVE
ACTIONS TODAY, INCLUDING BARRING
THE DOJ FROM CONTRACTING WITH
PRIVATE PRISONS, ENDING WHEN HE
CALLS RACIALLY DISCRIMINATORY
FEDERAL HOUSING POLICY, AND
ADDRESSING ANTI-ASIAN BIAS.
INCLUDING REFERENCES TO THE
COVID-19 PANDEMIC BY THE
GEOGRAPHIC LOCATION OF ITS
ORIGIN.
ACCORDING TO BIDEN, YOU’RE A
RACIST IF YOU CALL IT THE
WILHELM VIRUS.
I UNDERSTAND.
WRITE THAT DOWN.
IF YOU BELIEVE AMERICA’S
HOPELESSLY RACIST, IT’S AN
IRREDEEMABLE PLACE.
SOMETHING MUST BE WRONG WITH THE
EVIL FOUNDERS.
THUS BIDEN HAD TO OFFICIALLY
RENOUNCE ANY PRIOR EFFORTS TO
ESTABLISH PATRIOTIC EDUCATION
AND ELIMINATE TRUMP’S RACE BLIND
APPROACH TO WORKPLACE TRAINING.
>> I AM RESENDING THE PREVIOUS
ADMINISTRATION’S HARMFUL BAN ON
DIVERSITY AND SENSITIVITY
TRAINING AND ABOLISHING THE
OFFENSIVE COUNTERFACTUAL 1776
COMMISSION.
UNITY AND HEALING MUST BEGIN
WITH UNDERSTANDING AND TRUTH,
NOT IGNORANCE ON LIES.
>> Laura: DOES HE EVEN KNOW
WHAT HE’S READING?
YOU HAVE TO UNDERSTAND A
DISCUSSION OF THE WONDERS OF THE
AMERICAN FOUNDING IS NOW I GUESS
HE SAID THE WORDS, IN BIDEN’S
VIEW, A LIE.
IF YOU NOW BELIEVE WHAT MOST OF
US WERE TAUGHT IN SCHOOL THAT
OUR FOUNDING FATHERS WERE
BRILLIANT, HEROIC MEN --
NO ONE’S PERFECT, THEY MADE
MISTAKES.
THEY ALL HAD FLAWS, SOME BIG
FLAWS.
IF YOU THOUGHT THEY WERE
BRILLIANT, HEROIC MEN, YOUR
IGNORANT.
IF YOU PRAISE THE WISDOM OF THE
FRAMERS, YOU’RE A LIAR AND
PROBABLY A RACIST.
DOES BIDEN KNOW RENOUNCE HIS OWN
CATHOLIC EDUCATION?
HIS TEACHERS?
HIS PROFESSORS?
WHO CELEBRATED FOR INSTANCE THE
DECLARATION OF INDEPENDENCE AND
THE CONSTITUTION AS WELL AS THE
MEN WHO SENT THEM?
THE 1776 COMMISSION UNDERSTOOD
THAT AMERICA IS A GREAT NATION
THAT NEVERTHELESS MADE SOME
GRAVE ERRORS.
TODAY’S LEFT INVERTS THAT
BELIEF, INSISTING THAT WE ARE A
GRAVELY EVIL NATION THAT ONLY
OCCASIONALLY DOES SOME GOOD
THINGS.
LIKE ELECT OBAMA AND BIDEN.
>> HAVE NEVER FULLY LIVED UP TO
THE FOUNDING PRINCIPLES OF THE
NATION, TO STATE THE OBVIOUS,
THAT ALL PEOPLE ARE CREATED
EQUAL AND HAVE A RIGHT TO BE
TREATED EQUALLY THROUGHOUT THEIR
LIVES.
YOU KNOW, WE HAVE BOUGHT THE
VIEW THAT AMERICA IS A ZERO-SUM
GAME IN MANY CASES.
>> Laura: IT IS A WANDERER
THAT HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE APPLYING TO BECOME
AMERICAN CITIZENS EVERY YEAR
FROM ALL CORNERS OF THE EARTH.
NOW I’VE HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF
GETTING TO KNOW MANY OF THESE
HARDWORKING AND GRATEFUL NEW
AMERICANS, AND THEY ARE
EVERYWHERE FROM AFRICA,
CENTRAL AMERICA AND BEYOND
BEYOND.
AT TIMES IT SEEMS THAT THEY
UNDERSTAND MORE ABOUT THE
GOODNESS, PROMISE, THE
OPPORTUNITIES IN AMERICA THEN
THE VENGEFUL NATIVE-BORN
LEFTISTS TURNING OUT RACE-BASED
EXECUTIVE ORDERS FOR BIDEN.
YOU HAVE TO ASK YOURSELF, HOW
DID WE GET HERE?
FOR DECADES, RADICAL ACADEMICS
HAVE BEEN TEACHING STUDENTS TO
BELIEVE THAT WHITE PRIVILEGE IS
A GREATER THREAT TO US THAN THE
CCP, ISLAMIC TERROR, THE FORMER
SOVIET UNION, UNEMPLOYMENT, AND
CERTAINLY ANTIVIRUS.
NOW GETTY WITH A COMPLAINANT COM
IN THE WHITE HOUSE, THEY WANT
THOSE WHO DISAGREE TO BE SHAMED,
REEDUCATED, PUNISHED AND IN THAT
CASE OF TRUMP SUPPORTERS
PURGED COMPLETELY FROM SOCIETY.
I AM NOT EXAGGERATING THAT.
THERE WILL BE NO END TO THE
DEMANDS OF THESE RACIAL
RABBLE-ROUSERS.
I’M TALKING HUNDREDS OF BILLIONS
IF NOT TRILLIONS OF NEW SPENDING
SPENDING.
THEY BELIEVE THAT DANGLING THE
PROSPECT OF REPARATIONS WILL
OBSCURE THE FACT THAT THEIR
POLICIES JUST TO NAME A FEW --
OPEN BORDERS ON THE OFF SHORING
OF JOBS -- WILL MAKE
IMPOVERISHED AND WORKING-CLASS
AMERICANS OF ALL RACES POORER
AND LESS SAFE.
BUT NEVER FEAR.
THE WOMAN WHO LIED REPEATEDLY
ABOUT BENGHAZI WILL RIGHT ALL
WRONGS BY ASSUMING THAT IF YOU
ARE WHITE AND YOU SUCCEEDED AT
SOMETHING, IT MUST BE BECAUSE
YOU ROB SOMEONE ELSE OF A MORE
DESERVING OPPORTUNITY.
>> EVERY AGENCY WILL PLACE
EQUITY AT THE CORE OF THEIR
PUBLIC ENGAGEMENTS, THEIR POLICY
DESIGN AND PROGRAM DELIVERY.
TO ENSURE THAT GOVERNMENT
RESOURCES ARE REACHING AMERICANS
OF COLOR AND ALL MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES.
RURAL, URBAN, DISABLED, LGBTQ+,
RELIGIOUS MINORITIES IN SO MANY
OTHERS.
>> Laura: APPARENTLY AMERICA
IS SO RIGGED THAT SUSAN RICE
ATTENDED TWO OF THE COUNTRY’S
MOST ELITE INSTITUTIONS.
RIGHT HERE IN WASHINGTON, D.C.,
THE NATIONAL CATHEDRAL SCHOOL
AND ONTO STANFORD UNIVERSITY.
ACCEPTANCE AT STANFORD
UNIVERSITY STANDS AT ABOUT 4%.
COMPARE THAT TO SOMEONE LIKE
SHELBY STEELE, A CURRENT FELLOW
AT STANFORD’S HOOVER INSTITUTION
WHO SAID THIS ON OUR SHOW LAST
WEEK.
>> IS WHITE GUILT STILL AN
ANIMATING FORCE IN AMERICAN LIFE
LIFE?
IT WON’T -- WE WON’T EVER GET
BEYOND IT.
UNTIL WHITE AMERICA BEGINS TO
SEE TO LOSE ITS INSECURITY
AROUND RACE.
YES, WE DID HORRIBLE THINGS BUT
TODAY AMERICA IS REMARKABLY FREE
OF RACISM.
IF YOU’RE A BLACK PERSON IN
AMERICA TODAY, YOUR LIFE IS NOT
GOING TO BE STUNTED BY RACIAL
PERSECUTION.
>> Laura: NOW, IF WHAT RICE
AND THE REST OF THE BIDEN TEAM
ARE CLAIMING IS TRUE, THEN WHY
SHOULD WE ASK ANYONE HERE TO
SACRIFICE FOR THIS COUNTRY, FOR
INSTANCE IN THE MILITARY, AS A
MEMBER OF A POLICE FORCE,
FRANKLY ANY PUBLIC SERVANT.
WHY DID SUSAN RICE AS NATIONAL
SECURITY ADVISOR SIGN ONTO
SENDING OUR TROOPS ABROAD TO DIE
FOR THIS COUNTRY.
WHY WOULD A ROTTEN, RACIST, EVIL
CONTRIBUTE WORTH DEFENDING?
WHY WOULD WE WANT OUR
SYSTEMICALLY RACIST VALUES TO BE
EXPORTED ABROAD?
LET’S FACE IT.
THE DEMOCRATS KNOW ALL TOO WELL
THAT TRUMP GREW HIS POLITICAL
SUPPORT AMONG ALL MINORITIES
ESPECIALLY LATINOS AND ASIANS.
WHY DID HE DO THIS?
HIS POLICY DELIVERED RECORD LOW
UNEMPLOYMENT BLACKS AND
HISPANICS.
HOUSEHOLD INCOMES GREW FOR ALL
RACES AND ETHNICITIES.
THE LEFT HAS NEVER BEEN SERIOUS
ABOUT GROWING THE ECONOMY, HAS
IT?
BIDEN IS ALREADY KILLED
THOUSANDS OF GOOD PAYING JOBS
WITH HIS ATTACK ON OUR ENERGY
SECTOR.
NICE GOING, JOE.
SOON COMPANIES ARE RANDOMLY
MOVING ONCE AGAIN, JOBS BACK TO
CHINA AND OTHER COUNTRIES TO
AVOID HIS SMOTHERING REGULATIONS
AND CRIPPLING TAXES.
BUT BIDEN’S HANDLERS THINK THEY
CAN STILL KEEP MINORITY VOTERS
ON THE HOOK WITH IDENTITY
POLITICS, VIRTUALLY SIGNALING,
DIVERSITY QUOTAS, AND THE
PIPE DREAM OF REPARATIONS.
IT’S SO CYNICAL AND MORE THAN
THAT, IT’S SO INSULTING.
LIKE BIDEN’S PURPORTED DISDAIN
FOR EXECUTIVE ORDERS, THIS IS
ALL A FRAUD.
IT’S A CRUEL HOAX.
IT’S CRUEL BOTH TO MINORITIES
AND TO THE OVERWHELMINGLY GOOD
PEOPLE WHO MAKE UP OUR AMERICAN
FAMILY.
WE ON THE FLOOR IN ROOM -- ON
"THE INGRAHAM ANGLE," WE ARE
GOING TO CONTINUE TO ANSWER
THEIR TWISTED AND POISONOUS
CLAIMS AND WE WILL DO IT WITH
FACTS, LOVE, PATRIOTISM
AND SOMETIMES YES WELL ALL THE
TIME PRAYER.